I want to make sure we get to the clip I
know there's a clip here and we should
oh there should be a clip oh no you know
what
so here's the thing oh yeah we forgot
the clip we did we did not bring the
click says clip here and yeah we were
supposed to 100% we were supposed to
bring the clip so what we have is some
scripts we were hoping you would provide
us with some help with the clip it's
just cuz the Clips not here we just
thought we would do it like a little
reading now in this particular scene
you're gonna be playing Method Man
I'm Method Man that's it man yes yeah
and we need you to really go for it here
I just Street it up real real gritty
Street it up I can't think of a better
person to play Method Man George then
come on Bryan you're gonna be you're
gonna be Keanu in this all right I don't
have my glasses do I need any no lines
so we'll set up the scene in the scene
Method Man is playing cheddar the the
drug lord and gangster has his gang has
stolen keanue and we are pretending to
be hard hard grizzled thugs yes right in
order to infiltrate your gang I stole
your kitten I'm a gang leader and I'm my
part is played by Method Man correct yes
right and we're and we're masquerading
as drug dealers and here we go yes I'm
trying to get the cats use me I just
noticed this in the script yeah my first
line calls for me to use the n-word just
keep it real this one way into it lean
into it Conan no no
[Applause]
we're very understanding when a guy like
me uses that word you know what I'm
going to replace that with a different
with a different and one word how's that
there's there's thousands of N word yes
I'm gonna use one right now okay all
right all right so friends okay here we
go
hey uh it's a cute cat this is my
non-voter new jack but look ya'll go run
off and do your little tinkle it's
actually pretty good that sounds if I
don't were to close my eyes I think
Method Man was here this would be I
thought you would have a much worse
african-american dialect I really I was
not even trying to do Wow I don't see
color okay no idea all right
just going on so where'd you get them
mildly offensive that one all right now
the left sorry the left thought a little
stereotypical just just keep on the
right page so any n-word is so much yeah
this is okay it seems to me no stupidest
his right mind will let a cat go
willy-nilly
willy-nilly what though how much you
want for him he's serious
actually he is we're in the market right
now for a gangster pet
he ain't for Sam everything has his
price at a pet store
this ain't no mother cat store like i
said everything has oh what's that sorry
oh we drew up the clip oh there was no
need for pony to embarrass himself
there's no need for me to walk a razor
edge racial line my career for nothing
that was you that was you that that was
on me all right well let's roll the clip
from Keanu we'd have the clip from there
now
hey you can uh ya know Jack right here
man yeah
hey below before y'all go run off and do
your little thing where'd you get him
how much you want for him he's serious
actually he is man we in the market
right now for like a gangster pet so
[Applause]
you
you